نحن الان على بعد امتار قليله من المجمع
القضائي الذي من المفترض ان يقوم رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران بالوصول اليه تمهيدا
لمحاكمته في قضيه رفعت اليه يحاول قوات
الشرطه وهي قوات شرطه اسلام اباد تفريق
المتظاهرين المؤيدين لرئيس الوزراء عمران
خان وهي تقوم باستخدام الغاز المسين
للدموع بينما يقوم المتظاهرين
برميهم في الحجاره من الجهه الاخرى هناك
حاله من الفوضى في محيط المجمع القضايش
رغم اصدار السلطات هنا في اسلام اباد لفرض
قانون يسمى قانون الطوارئ في محاوله بوقت
التجمعات المؤيده لرئيس الوزراء وفي
محاوله
كل التظاهرات المؤيده لهم هناك حاله من
الفوضى في كل المحيط محيط بعض الخرائقه في
تلك المنطقه كما نلاحظ ان الدخان والغاز
قد وصل الى الاحياء السكنيه شاهدنا عدد من
المواطنين وشهدنا عدد من المدنيين وهم
يعانون من وجود الغاز الغاز كميات الغاز
كميات كبيره جدا التي يتم يتم
رمش على المتظاهرين بينما يقوم انصار خان
الموجودون في الجهه الاخرى نشاهد انهم
يقومون برمي الحجاره على قوات الشرطه التي
ترد عليهم باستخدام الغاز المسير للدموع
ماذا لم يعرف حتى الان ان كانت ستجرى
محاكمه لعمران خان واما اذا كانت سيتمه
وتاجيلها في ظل وجود هذه الفوضى في محيط
المجمع القضائي كما يخشى البعض هنا فان
تتسع دائره الغضب في محيط باكستان كامل في
حال اصدرت المحكمه
قرارا بسجن رئيس الوزراء عمران خامس سمير
النمري الجزيره اسمع اباد